I'm now joined by Rory challenge he is
following developments for us from Kiev
Rory as we're seeing this Ukrainian push
continue we are also seeing some
perceived retaliation from Moscow
yes and again it's the civilians of the
city of zaparisia that seem to be
experiencing the worst of Russia's rage
the city has been pounded repeatedly
over recent Days by Russian airstrikes
and missile strikes it's indiscriminate
at best at worst it seems intentional
that's how most ukrainians interpret it
is why they describe Russia as a
terrorist State and last night's again
there were strikes on civilian targets
it seems with a high-rise building being
hit many houses being hit the death toll
as we understand it at the moment is 17
five houses destroyed 40 damage the
authorities in zaprasia City say that
the Russian airplanes launched at least
12 missiles at the city now is that
retaliation it's yeah you can't look
into the minds of the Russian military
and safer sure at the moment but
certainly the Russians are smarting
after the attack on the Kirch Bridge
yesterday an attack for which the
ukrainians still have not uh explicitly
said they were responsible lots more
insinuation today lots more hints in his
uh direct video address to the nation
last night president zielinski framed it
as a weather report saying that over
most of Ukraine conditions were good and
sunny but over Crimea it was a bit
cloudy
Rory challenge their following
developments from Kiev for us thank you
so much Rory